- It's You Up, with Nikki
Glaser.
Two guests in the studio now,
two huge guests, oh my gosh.
Pete Holmes, Judd Apatow,
welcome to the show.
- I'd like to talk about
Blink for a second.
- I have Blink-182.
- You do?
- Yeah.
- I don't like the fact that
there's cameras everywhere
because there's things I wanna
do
that I don't want seen on video.
So I assume like the street
where I live,
everyone has cameras.
But what if I'm mad at a
neighbor
and wanna slash their tires,
can I not do that now?
- I think you still can.
- You can?
- That's what the burlap sack
is for.
- That's true, and you can
watch yourself do it later on.
- Okay, I can still harass
people somehow.
- Yes.
- Yeah, no you can still
be the vandal that we
know and love you as.
- Okay, good.
(rock music)
- Judd is a real rascal.
- Is he?
- He'll throw bricks
at corporations.
(both laughing)
He's lit me on fire more than
once.
- Are you like a prankster,
Judd, at all?
- He's a prankster.
- I would never do it, but I
like the idea that I could.
- I hate pranks.
- I hate pranks--
- Can we swear on this?
- So much, yes.
- Fuck you, prank!
(goofy voice) Hey Pete,
uh there's a package
outside for you.
(normal voice) I open the
door, there's nothing.
(goofy yelling)
- I hate 'em.
- You're a liar,
you're a dick and I believed
you.
You took advantage of my
open heart, shame on you.
- You know when people
prank people and they go,
"Oh and I'm just kidding!"
I'll never forget when I
didn't know you were kidding.
(Pete laughing)
And that will stay with me
forever and color the way I look
at you
and interact with you the rest
of my life.
- That's right.
- I didn't trust you for the--
Even if you go, "You look
ugly today, just kidding!"
That second of being like.
(gasps)
- Adam Sandler used to do
this thing, back in the day,
when we lived together
when we were young kids.
Which it bugged me so much,
which is,
he would call me
and he would try to, he
would show interest in me,
in my life,
and try to get me to
open up about something,
and then as soon as I got
emotional and opened up
he would hang up on me.
(Nikki laughing)
- Oh...
- And he would do it all the
time.
And it was always like could
he just trick me into thinking
it wasn't happening.
- God.
- So it would be like, "So
what happened with Wendy,
did you guys talk, like did
you find out why she was
so upset?"
And then I'd go, you know I
don't know we're just struggling
and then I'd just hear click.
- Wow, that's what we lost
when we lost the click.
Humel will do that to me, he'll
text me and he'll be like,
"Oh my god I was just doing
a show and they just couldn't
stop talking about how you
are their favorite comedian."
And he'll do that for like
thirty minutes.
He'll be like, "I can't
remember, I can't remember."
And then I'll be like, "Who was
it?"
"Oh right, it was my mother."
(both laughing)
And he was just like,
"Fuck you!
Fuck you, you think it's
gonna be John Mayer?"
I want that sweet Mayer, not
your mother.
(both laughing)
Mayer not mother!
- You want to hear that Mayer's
a big fan?
- I'm sure you've met
John Mayer doing comedy.
- Well we all want Mayer's
approval.
- I mean Val is up for
it, and Johnny go ahead.
Bring some picks, 'cause
she's gonna wanna hear
a song afterwards.
- God everyone wants
that Mayer, what is it?
- Dude, I understand.
He's dreamy, he's got
the one dangerous arm,
the one regular arm.
You know what I mean.
He's got rings, like Johnny Depp
rings.
One of the rings is like around
his neck.
I get it, I'm not even
roasting him, he's dreamy!
- I was at a charity event
and they were auctioning off
John Mayer will sing Your
Body's A Wonderland right now,
to you.
And so I bid and won it for
him to do it to my wife.
And so they put a chair on the
stage,
and this is on YouTube
if you wanna see it,
and he starts looking in my
wife's eyes.
- Oh no.
- Oh my god.
- And it was gettin' intense.
And then I just got on stage
and stood right behind my wife.
- That's hilarious.
- To ruin the effect,
I think you could find that on
YouTube.
- What I don't understand
are all the young girls
that love John and think he's
like their dream boyfriend.
And I'm like, you realize
he's having sex with tens
of thousands of you guys, right?
It's like, "He's gonna whisk me
away!"
No, no he's not.
- They don't wanna be
whisked, they just want to be
one of them.
- I get it, I take it back.
- Yeah maybe they do.
- I take it back.
- But I think you're right,
there is something that like
you convince yourself no he
would just settle down with me.
- That's what I mean.
There's a fantasy, especially
with younger people
that are like, "No, no I
could tame the bad arm."
- It's like how I felt about
Cheryl Tiegs.
- Yes!
- Or Sheryl Crow!
- Yeah.
- Any of the Crow, Sheryl's.
I said the wrong one!
Any of the Crows, Russell.
But I made it up.
- Cameron.
Oh M G.
No question mark on the You Up?
- No.
- 'Cause it's that kind of text.
- It's just You Up.
- You Up.
That's a good touch.
- We're tellin' you.
- Oh, you're saying, it's
declarative.
- You better be up.
- But it's also You Up question,
I'm presuming it's a guy texting
you,
he doesn't even throw in
punctuation.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- Where we're going baby
we don't need punctuation.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, that's just so
disrespectful to not even have
a question mark with the You Up.
He's just giving it that little
effort.
- It gets less sexy
when you're like married
and you're sending it to
your husband or your wife
at 6:30 in the morning
and it's like, "You up?
Okay then, can you drive
the kids to school today?"
(Pete and Nikki laughing)
- I just had a baby so I'm
constantly checking if she's up.
'Cause you check if they
breathe, it's like a real thing.
People are paranoid.
You get up to pee and you're
like oh everything's fine,
I'm sure she's fine, she's in
her crib.
And then you're like,
what if that's the time?
- Yes.
- You gotta check.
You could be super dad,
it's a real fear obviously.
- Do you ever get tempted
to text your baby?
- I text my baby. (laughs)
- Do you ever like?
I remember when I got a dog I
was like
I just wanna text my dog.
- That's hilarious.
You have that instinct
that you can't do.
- I have a joke in my
new special about that.
I said if my dog had a
cellphone,
I would have 384 missed calls
right now.
(Nikki laughs)
And 7,000 texts of the bone
emoji and the walk emoji.
- You should get a
phone for your baby now.
Text just all the time and
then one day she'll just be
able to turn on the phone,
and she'll be able to read,
and she'll have years--
- Of our texts!
- Of your texts.
- Like you don't remember
sending these to me?
- Well that's kind of a great
idea.
- Wait, I'm a genius.
- You kind of, I mean.
I love going back through my
baby book and like reading
funny things that I said that
my parents just had the--
- Aw!
- Wherewithal to jot down
in that moment.
- My parents called me Paul
for the first four years.
Which is weird 'cause
they made up the name!
Paul!
- Are you keeping track
of the cute, funny things?
- What are some that you said?
No, I mean, our baby's
only three months old.
- Oh okay, so not doing a lot.
- Well she's yeah.
- I can't believe three months
Pete, congratulations.
- Thank you.
I was just gonna say, nobody
gives a shit about your baby
that's what I've learned.
- That's true, that is very
true.
- I was talking to Rob Riggle
about it
and he was like, especially
in L.A., he's like.
No, I understand that you care.
- I thought you're not
supposed to feel that,
I thought we were supposed
to keep that to ourselves
that we don't care.
I didn't know that you knew
that.
- We know.
- You know how we know,
it's how long people will
pretend to look at your baby
when you show them the picture.
- You need to find other new
parents,
those are the only people that
maybe
and all we wanna do is
look at your baby and go,
"Not as cute as my fucking
baby."
- Not as cute as mine.
- Fuck your baby.
- You get jealous too.
Like your baby's very cute.
So there's a part of you that's
just like,
"How do you get a cute baby?"
- Were you so excited when she
was cute?
- It is, we kept saying.
- You know she was gonna be
cute anyway, come on.
- That's so fun.
We kept going like,
"It's not just us, right?
This is like a fucking cute
baby."
Like you have to go it's not us.
- Yeah, yeah.
And people are telling you
your baby should model,
like that's I feel like the
general thing.
When I see a--
- Your baby should model.
- Like not model, but like
it should be on diaper bags
and stuff.
- She does, she could move
some mashed up carrots.
I think so.
There's also that great Seinfeld
bit,
"No one wants to go to your
wedding!"
Isn't that great?
I don't know the whole
bit, just the premise.
That's what I'm looking
for in stand-up comedy.
No one wants to go to your
wedding.
Like a secret that you
think, like we all thought
that people getting married
didn't know that we all
fucking don't want to go to your
wedding.
(Judd laughing)
He outed us.
That's the greatest feeling you
can get
at a stand-up comedy show.
- Well your baby looks
so much like you that--
- It feels impolite.
It really did!
She came out and I was like, "Oh
no!"
(laughing)
You're supposed to go
50, 50 with your wife!
You're supposed to puff,
puff, pass but like a little
slimy me came out and I was just
like
well, it's mine.
Like it was fucking weird.
As she's gotten older she
looks a little bit more like
the mom, but I look like my
wife.
We're like twin-cest.
Have you ever heard of
twin-cest?
Apparently I know what
I'm into and it's me.
(laughing)
- It makes sense, Pete.
You're a narcissist.
We all are.
- Dude, I know
I was like let's just throw the
dog a bone
- I love that.
- I think that's more
comfortable than me where you
know I just look like a beast
and just nothing.
Then the kids really hate if
anyone says they look like me.
There's no bigger insult
to them than to be like,
"You look a lot like your dad!"
It's like, "What?"
That hurts.
- I get that a lot too
with my dad,
the older I get.
- But Maude is beautiful
and she does look like you.
Like you can see.
- Well I think that is
why she looks beautiful.
(Pete laughing)
- Judd, I have never been
able to tell you this,
but you're very beautiful.
- They don't wanna take
on the Jewish, goofy side
of their genetic heritage.
- (goofy voice) Tell them that
Jewish goof
bought this house!
My dysfunction, I don't
know why it's Kennedy,
my dysfunction and my goofy
appearance
is why I wrote those films.
- (goofy voice) It's because I'm
Jewish!
(Pete laughing)
- This Judaism is what brought
the cable guy from a rom
into a dark comedy.
(all laughing)
I don't know why Kennedy.
- People do look like the
people they end up with.
A lot of times.
- Or they start
looking like them, right?
- Or yes, yes.
- Right?
I mean but it can go both ways.
- Yeah.
In all seriousness, there's
a lot I love about Val
and it does not have to do with
the fact
that she looks like me.
- No of course not.
- Every Instagram people are
like, "You fucking yourself?"
- Really?
- "Ay, you found you a tits?
Ay!"
- Did you post one of those
2018, 2008,
ten year part things?
- No!
- I didn't either.
- I couldn't find a picture
of me passed out at an Arby's.
- The worst part about that
is in the last ten years
I've completely crumbled.
It's all fallen apart.
So my wife, we have like a
wall of photos over the years
in the hallway.
And my wife just looks
the same for decades,
she's like a female
Paul Rudd or something.
- She is.
- And I'm just losing hair
and going gray and falling
apart.
- It's the stress of being
with a statuesque woman.
- Yes, yes, she's...
- It's your beauty!
- She's a healthy person, and
I'm not.
And now she's just looking
at me like, "Are you ever
gonna get it together?"
- She does have some like,
there's something going on
with your wife.
- I've seen your fridge.
- That is reversed.
- There's a lot of antioxidants
in there.
- She said,
- There's a lot of
sweet fruits.
- She said, "When we go out,
it looks like an old weird man
paid for a very expensive
Russian hooker."
(Pete and Nikki laughing)
- I wanna be in that
relationship.
- Yeah you can either have
twin-cest or hooker and.
- I'm gonna have it all.
- Prostitute, forgive me, and
pimp.
- We always, whenever we go to
restaurants
or out.
- Pimps will never be like,
"Don't call us pimps."
By the way, they'll always
be like, "No, we're pimps."
They're not like, "We are
sellers of fine, nighttime,
evening style sex."
(all laughing)
They're like, "No, we're pimps!"
- Whenever we go out to clubs,
not we don't go to clubs,
but like restaurants,
we always look around and
for some reason my wife
always thinks that the women are
hookers.
She's like, "I think that's
a hooker with that guy."
Like she doesn't believe in the
couple.
- Oh yeah.
- She thinks there must be
a financial arrangement.
- Yes.
- And she's always sniffing
that out.
I'm like is that really
happening in these places?
- I think so.
- Have you ever done crowd
work and realized in the middle
that the guy's with a
prostitute?
- No, really?
- I have, I've been like,
"Hello sir, that's your date?
She's looking sparkly.
What's your name?
Mercedes?
Wait a minute."
Like I'm moving on!
(rock music)